quante belle facce anche se siete in
penombra riesco a vederle lo stesso mi
presento sono Antonella e sono una
lettrice di facce per questo che mi
conosce mi chiama l'Anto delle facce
per stare in tema di cosa fa la
differenza Qualcuno potrebbe chiedersi
ma cosa fa la differenza tra una
lettrice di facce e uno che non lo è
nel mio caso la fanno delle cicatrici ma
per spiegarvelo meglio devo tornare
indietro di tantissimi anni fa era il 15
novembre
1962 e io avevo tre anni questo momento
state facendo il conto di quanti anni ho
quel giorno stavo giocando in cucina
mentre mio padre stava cambiando da un
vecchio fornello a gas e la bombola su
questo fornello a gas Mia madre aveva
messo a cuocere una bella dose generosa
di brodo bollente con della pastina
stellina non si sa bene Per quale motivo
tutto il contenuto di questa pentola
si è riversato addosso a me
ustione di secondo e terzo grado che ha
coinvolto la mia faccia mio collo le mie
spalle il mio corpo
salva per miracolo ma il miracolo più
grande è stato questo allora del tempo
le mie cicatrici quelle del corpo
purtroppo sono rimaste
lasciandomi Comunque anche delle
problematiche sia fisiche che
psicologiche ma magicamente dal mio
volto giorno per giorno mese per mese le
cicatrici sono scomparse
tutte le persone intorno a me per
consolare un po' questa bambina che
aveva questo questa problematica di
queste cicatrici nel corpo mi dicevano
Ma pensa se ti fossero rimaste in faccia
Pensa avresti potuto avere la faccia
rovinata Insomma facevano carico su
questa cosa allora io un giorno ho detto
va bene da grande studierò le facce
Allora mentre le mie amiche di scuola
volevano fare da grande il medico la
parrucchiera l'estetista eccetera io
volevo fare la giusta attrice di facce
ma non sapevo bene poi in che modo
Diciamo che questa cosa poi è stata
anche enfatizzata da mio padre che prima
di morire sentendosi responsabile di
quello che era successo di questo
incidente domestico Mi ha detto Fai
qualcosa per queste cicatrici
Allora io credo che siamo spesso nel
posto giusto al momento giusto e per me
quel posto giusto momento giusto è
arrivato nel 1996 Allora facevo un corso
di naturopatia e ho partecipato a un
congresso a Riccione che si intitolava
l'uomo e il mistero tra tutti i vari
relatori che illustravano varie
discipline una in particolare Mi è
risuonata dentro si trattava di un
relatore francese che illustrava la
morfo psicologia quindi la lettura del
volto attraverso L'osservazione delle
forme
è stato amore a prima vista non per il
relatore che comunque è diventato mio
amico ed è diventato mio maestro Ma per
la disciplina perché in quel momento ho
risentito quella promessa che mi ero
fatta da bambina di studiare le facce Mi
sono rivista quella bambina che non
andava mai al mare per non indossare un
costume da bagno e più avanti quella
donna che non ha mai messo un abito
scollato
quindi finisce questo questo intervento
di questo relatore lo inseguo subito e
dico io voglio fare questa cosa insomma
tre anni dopo mi trovavo nel nelle mani
il diploma di morfo psicologia
rilasciato dalla società francese di
Parigi e da lì è iniziato ufficialmente
il mio percorso verso lo studio delle
facce ma soprattutto la mia passione
quindi non è mai passato un giorno senza
che io non abbia cercato di studiare di
guardare in faccia alle persone di
osservare i dettagli e per essere ancora
più accreditata o anche mi sono anche
laureata in scienze e tecniche
psicologiche perché lo sappiamo bene che
non possiamo andare in giro a raccontare
se non abbiamo comunque una laurea
soprattutto nel mio caso mi dicevano Ma
tu come fai comunque guardi in faccia
alle persone e dici delle cose
diciamo che qualcuno voleva anche
provocarmi nel senso Ma come è possibile
effettivamente tu dici Vuoi dire come
siamo fatti Ma noi nella realtà lo
sappiamo come siamo fatti nella realtà
Certo ognuno di noi si conosce Ma magari
non fino in fondo non riesce a cogliere
e a capire quali sono i propri veri
Talenti perché spesso siamo molto
giudicanti nei confronti di noi stessi e
anche delle persone che incontriamo
Questo invece è proprio l'esatto opposto
del messaggio che voglio comunque
lasciarvi io prima di tutto un messaggio
forte è questo voi siete voi che
costruite il vostro volto è una cosa
importante questa proprio perché tutto
quello che all'interno di noi tutte le
sensazioni le emozioni le esperienze che
noi viviamo ma soprattutto l'ambiente
Quindi come ci relazioniamo con
l'ambiente fa la differenza e tutto
quello che all'interno di noi si
proietta all'esterno
alzi la mano chi non guarda in faccia
una persona a volte dicendo Ma oggi Hai
una faccia che non mi piace oppure
qualcuno tutti lo facciamo al mattino ci
guardiamo allo specchio Diciamo che
faccia da paura che ho si dice così no
oggi Ecco in realtà tutti facciamo un
osservazione del nostro volto a volte
impietoso Allora per quelle persone un
pochettino
diversamente giovani come me vi lascio
un trucchetto Allora gli indiani
d'America dicevano ognuno porta sul
volto la polvere del sentiero che ha
percorso Io mi sono scritto sullo
specchio del bagno così al mattino
quando mi guardo dico ma no è polvere e
vado felice contenta
farei le facce in modo che si veda
l'anima Questo era il grande Leonardo da
Vinci ancora prima Cicerone diceva nel
volto c'è tutto proprio perché come
dicevo prima tutto quello che sono le
nostre esperienze di vita vengono a
riflettersi sul volto Ma in che modo
Allora vi spiego un attimino la legge
fondamentale di questa di questa moderna
fisiognomica perché voi avete sentito
parlare della fisiognomica che era
praticamente la disciplina Antica Dove
appunto dall'osservazione dei tratti del
volto si potevano cogliere Il
temperamento delle persone ma questa
disciplina non teneva conto di questo
famoso concetto olistico cioè che ogni
cosa va sempre considerata tutto
nell'insieme quindi era molto giudicante
perché diceva per esempio il Lombroso
della situazione qualcuno l'avrà sentito
nominare diceva se quella persona ha il
cranio in questo modo ha il naso in
questo modo è così così e diventava una
cosa molto molto
giudicante mentre invece la disciplina
che ho studiato io che arriva appunto
dalla Francia e si chiama morfo
psicologia dice che ogni dettaglio va
sempre visto nel contesto quindi un naso
non va considerato solo per quello che è
in questo forno Ma va considerato per
quello che è tutto l'interno e poi cosa
succede che nel nostro volto sono
comunque ci sono tutte espresse tutte le
funzioni e ci sono tutti i nostri organi
sensoriali naso bocca orecchie e guarda
caso sono sette aperture 7 non è un
numero casuale perché è un numero con
una valenza universale simbolica molto
grande Ecco praticamente io quando
guardo un volto e tutti mi dicono ma
come fai a dire queste cose io
scherzando dico ormai è un po' il
compasso negli occhi perché vado proprio
a vedere le forme come le misure delle
forme come queste forme si esprimono ma
sulla base di una legge naturale
biologica e fondamentale che è la legge
della dilatazione e la legge della
ritrazione quindi la legge dell'apertura
e la legge della chiusura
tutto in natura qualsiasi essere vivente
si muove su questa polarità quindi
l'apertura e la chiusura se noi siamo in
difficoltà cosa facciamo Ci chiudiamo se
mentre Siamo invece in un momento
favorevole ci apriamo esattamente nel
nostro volto succedono le stesse
identiche cose Tutto mosso da una spinta
interiore che dall'interno va a
riflettersi sull'esterno Sapete qual è
nel volto il dettaglio che si modifica
di più è il naso e adesso vi spiego con
una metafora il motivo Allora dovete
immaginare che il nostro volto sia la
nostra casa viaggiante tutti noi abbiamo
una casa fissa Dove dove dimoriamo e poi
abbiamo la nostra casa che ci portiamo
in giro
è una casa rappresenta la casa perché il
tetto e la nostra testa Poi abbiamo la
struttura della casa in questo caso e
questa è la cornice che è la parte
Diciamo che nel corso della nostra vita
si modifica di meno e diciamo la
struttura della casa così è e così la
teniamo poi abbiamo l'intonaco intonaco
che è la nostra pelle che quello che
magari dipingiamo che quella che si
scrosta che quello che che si segna ecco
dicevo il naso perché il naso
praticamente è quello che si modifica di
più perché della nostra casa è quello è
il balcone e quello che sta all'esterno
e quello che sporge ed è quello che
prende di più è soggetto a tutte le
influenze esterne lo sappiamo in una
casa del nostro balcone e quello che è
soggetto alle intemperie ma non solo per
quello è la parte che si modifica di più
ma perché nel per fare una corretta
lettura del volto possiamo facciamo
anche andare a cercare le funzioni
principali Dove sono collocate Qui
abbiamo il pensiero qui in questa parte
abbiamo il sentimento e qui abbiamo
l'istinto Ecco che guardando le forme e
i movimenti di queste zone si riesce a
capire come la persona funziona a
livello di pensiero come la persona
funziona a livello di sentimento e come
funziona a livello distinto quindi una
mascella importante ci parlerà di una
persona decisa
degli occhi molto incavati ci parleranno
di una persona che a livello di pensiero
perché gli occhi sono strettamente
collegati col pensiero una persona
introspettiva e via cioè i dettagli sono
tantissime le cose che potrei dirvi sono
tantissime ma quello che mi interessa
passare come messaggio e che il nostro
volto fa la differenza e quando
incontriamo il volto di un'altra persona
persona Cerchiamo di non giudicarlo ma
di accoglierlo perché quella persona
quel volto se l'è costruito con tutte le
sue esperienze con tutte le sue
sensazioni con le emozioni ma
soprattutto con l'interazione con
l'ambiente perché se noi siamo in un
ambiente favorevole ci apriamo se siamo
invece in un ambiente dove siamo un
pochino in disagio Ci chiudiamo se io
adesso fossi qua Comunque a parlare di
questa cosa tutta messa in questo modo
credo che il messaggio non passerebbe
allo stesso modo Mentre invece io sono
qua in apertura felice di essere qua a
comunicare a parlare con voi della mia
passione e in questo modo Sto così in
apertura Ecco questo Diciamo che il
meccanismo che muove tutto tutto quello
che è la lettura del volto
io quello che Auguro a voi è che sul
vostro volto possa sempre esprimersi
tanta gioia 170 serenità tanto amore e
che quando appunto incontrate il volto
delle altre persone non non state a
guardare il dettaglio questo è bello
questo non è bello perché poi si tratta
non né di bellezza né di altro ma di
concetti di armonia ci piace qualche
cosa quando Comunque è proporzionata
quando comunque c'è Armonia all'interno
di questa forma e ricordate che comunque
la forma esprime sempre un contenuto
quindi vi auguro che il vostro contenuto
sia sempre dei migliori e che la vostra
forma lo possa esprimere al mondo come
dice quel famoso mago non credete ma
verificate e quindi da oggi potrete
Comunque magari essere un pochettino un
pochettino più indulgenti con le forme
del vostro volto con i difetti che
magari non vi piacciono ma sapete che
questa volta ve lo siete creati voi
Quindi non potete più dare la colpa alla
mamma al papà certo c'entra il DNA
perché Qualcuno può dirmi ma il DNA
Assolutamente sì concorrono tutta una
sorta di cose a fare quello che è il
nostro volto Ma pensate per esempio ai
bambini adottivi che la maggior parte
vengono da somigliare poi alla famiglia
anche se non è ai genitori anche se non
è non sono biologici pensate alle coppie
che vivono in simbiosi e tendono ad
assomigliarsi proprio perché sì c'è una
parte di DNA che fa che forma Comunque
quello che è il nostro esterno ma è
proprio come Noi spendiamo il nostro
bagaglio genetico e energetico nel mondo
Questo fa assolutamente la differenza su
quelle che poi sono le nostre forme
Anche perché nel corso comunque della
nostra esistenza cambiano si modificano
da bambini abbiamo questo volto Rotondo
morbido passivo perché non siamo
comunque ancora proiettati in tutto
quello che è il mondo vero e proprio poi
cresciamo diventiamo degli adolescenti e
Pensate cosa succede nel nostro volto da
adolescente e praticamente si inclina di
terza se noi lo guardiamo di traverso
avremo comunque una fronte tutto
inclinato proprio perché c'è una spinta
La natura manda una spinta a questa a
questo volto dell'adolescente perché gli
adolescente deve andare verso il mondo
Quando poi arriviamo all'etàmmature
invece in tutto questo si raddrizza per
poi arrivare Comunque nel nell'età
estrema quando Comunque abbiamo torniamo
in ritrazione ci difendiamo perché Siamo
comunque arrivati a più o meno alla fine
della nostra vita e quindi siamo
comunque un pochino più in difficoltà
quindi non abbiamo più questo viso
rotondo del bambino ma abbiamo comunque
queste forme più in ritrazione e più in
difesa Quindi il nostro mondo fa il
nostro volto fa un viaggio all'interno
del mondo sta a noi comprenderlo amarlo
e rispettarlo io concludo con la frase
che dico sempre a tutti buona faccia
Grazie